WITH ITEM ONE WELCOME SOBRE
WOULD AB THIRTY EIGHT. THE
FLOOR IS YOURS SIR. THIRTY
EIGHT BACK. THANK YOU FOR
CALLING THREE FAILED. OUR
SYSTEM DOES MORE. WE HAVE AN-
YEAH OKAY LET'S GO AHEAD THIS
HOUR SCORN BEFORE MR WERE NEXT
PRESENTATION. TO CALL THE ROLL.
HERE GREAT HERE BIGELOW PRESENT
BIGELOW HERE AGUIAR-CURRY.
BERMAN YEAH BERMAN HERE FUN
STUFF FUNDS HERE BRO BRO HERE
COOLEY. THERE ARE LOW HERE LOW
HERE MATHIS. MATHIS HERE
MELENDEZ MELENDEZ HERE QUIRK
SILVA QUIRK SILVA IS HERE RIVAS.
RUBIO YOUR RUBIO HERE SALAS
SALAS HERE. OF CORD PRESENT
WHICH WERE BUILT AND YOU CAN
TAKE PROTECTION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF AB THIRTY EIGHT THIS
WAS ONE OF A NUMBER OF THIS
YEAR THE RESPONSE THE WILD CARD
CRISIS WE'RE EXPERIENCING
CALIFORNIA YOU KNOW THEY'RE
DOING HOMES IN HIGH FIRES AT
AND HAS ITS OWN THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA THAT WERE BUILT
BEFORE WE IMPLEMENTED THE WILD
AND INTERFACE BUILDING CODES
WHICH ARE DESIGNED TO TACKLE
FOR WILDFIRES BY NUMBERS TO GO
INTO HOMES COUSIN FOR DOWN FROM
THE INSIDE OUT. AB THIRTY EIGHT
IS PROPOSING THE FIRST EVER
STATEWIDE RETROFIT FIRE WHITES
THE WHITES PIRATES GROUP.
PROGRAM IN CALIFORNIA. THE
OWNERS OF THESE OLDER HOME. I'M
SORRY FOR THEIR HOMES TO MAKE
THEM MORE LIKELY TO. FIGHT THE
FIRES. WE HAVE RECORD THAT
PROGRAM FOR EARTHQUAKES AND
ENERGY EFFICIENCY BUT
RETROFITTING FOR FIRE IN. THE
SENSE AND MEETING CHALLENGES
FOR TO MAKE A FIRE THAT PROGRAM
AFFECTED WE MUST GET HOMEOWNERS
TO COOPERATE AND REFERENCE
RETROFITTING GROUPS.
REFRIGERATE GROUPS OF HOMES
COLLECTIVELY. JUST ONE HOUSE ON
THE BLOCK RECORD AS THEIR HOME
IN THE REST OF THE NEIGHBORS DO
NOT FOR THOSE AFFECTED HOMES.
CAN PROVIDE MORE THAN ENOUGH
FUEL TO BURN DOWN EVEN WAS PART
OF THE FALLS. THIS DRESS THE
UNIQUE DYNAMIC THIS UNIQUE
DYNAMIC EIGHT THIRTY INCREASE
OF PILOT PROGRAMS. THE LAST
COUNT FIRING WE HAVE TO WORK
TOGETHER FOR YOU AS A BROAD
RANGE OF FUNDING AND THE
CLEANING EXISTING FEDERAL
FUNDS. PRIVACY TARGET AT RISK
COMMUNITIES. THE FIVE YEAR
PILOT PROJECT THAT ALLOWS THE
DEPARTMENTS TO REPORT BACK. I
REQUIRES PARTIES REPORT BACK
LISTEN TO HIM FOR YEARS ABOUT
THE VALUE OF THE PROJECT.
PROGRESS IN ADDITION TO THE
REST OF THE PROGRAM. AB EIGHT
THIRTY EIGHT ATTEMPTS TO
EDUCATE HOME BUYERS IN FIRE
PRONE AREAS BY REQUIRING SO IS.
THAT SO FEW OF THE WEEK
BUILDING CODES WERE IMPLEMENTED
TO. BUYERS THIS TESTIFIED FOR.
HIS EXIST ON ALL. THOSE
INJURIES FROM BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT ABOUT THE PROCESS. AND
RECENT AMENDMENTS. ALL
OPPOSITION RESPECT WITH. WHO
BELIEVE IT IS. THE GRANT
PROGRAM. REMAIN WITH HIM. I
JUST GOT THE RECORD FOR NEXT
SESSION YOU AND I HAVE TALKED
ABOUT THIS I THINK PRIVATELY
THE EXTENT TO WHICH WE
CANNIBALIZED EXISTING GRANT
FUNDS THAT MIGHT OTHERWISE
GOING TO EARTHQUAKE FLOOD. YOU
CAN DO THAT THIS BILL THAT'S A
SUBJECT WE MAY HAVE TO REVISIT
NEXT YEAR TO INSURE. WE'RE
BALANCING ALL THOSE MITIGATION
PROGRAMS ACROSS THE BOARD I WAS
AND I THINK THIS TIME SO IT'S-
A GOOD BILL. YEAH IF I COULD
JUST ADD ON TO WHAT THE
CHAIRMAN JUST SAID. WHILE I'M
HESITANT ON ON THE BILL. I'M
ENCOURAGED BY WHAT IT'S GOING
TO DO WHICH IS SAFE HOMES AND
TO SOME THINGS THE HESITATION
IS THE COST AND WITH THE
ABSENCE OF THE GRANT FUNDING
COMPONENT IN THERE I THINK THE
NEXT SESSION WE NEED TO FOCUS
ON THAT AND GET THAT FUNDING
BUT IN THEIR BEFORE TODAY WITH
WHAT IT DOES IN THE OTHER
COMPONENTS OF THE BILL
ARTICULATING. WHAT MAKES SOME
THINGS MORE REASONABLE THAN.
ARE IN THE OTHER PIECES OF
LEGISLATION THAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO FIX I APPLAUD YOU FOR THAT
SO. WITH THAT I ENCOURAGE AYE.
OKAY WE HAVE ANY TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT THIS TIME. ISN'T THAT
WHERE YOU'RE COMFORTABLE. MOST
ARE MERIWETHER CALIFORNIA THEY
GET CONSERVATION VOTERS IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND I WAS
ALSO. BECAUSE THEY ARE CA WORDS.
THANK YOU. IN ADDITIONAL TEST
ONE SUPPORT SEEING ON A TEST
TWENTY OPPOSITION. SEEING NO WE
HAVE A MOTION A SECOND CHECK TO
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THE MOTION
IS CUTTING HER WITH SENATE
AMENDMENTS TO THE COMMITTEE ON
NATURAL RESOURCES GRAY AYE GRAY
AYE BIGELOW. BIGELOW AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY. BERMAN BERMAN I
LIVE ON SO BONTA I'D THROW ROLL
AYE COOLEY. COOLEY AYE COOPER I
DALY REALLY I GALLAGHER
GALLAGHER AYE GARCIA. GIPSON
HI. I JONES SAWYER JONES SAWYER
AYE LACKEY LACKEY AYE LOW. LOW
I'D MATHIS THIS AYE MELINDA.
MELENDEZ NOT VOTING QUIRK SILVA
QUIRK SILVA AYE ROBERT RIVAS.
RUBIO AYE RUBIO AYE SALAS AYE
SALAS AYE. THE BILL HAS
SEVENTEEN BOXES OUT THANK YOU
MISTER WITH. OKAY THIS CHAIR
YET MAYBE EIGHTEEN TWENTY FIVE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO GIVE A
LENGTHY DISSERTATION I KNOW YOU
HAVE A NUMBER OF TALKING POINTS
THAT ARE. WHETHER VERY SPECIFIC
AND ARTICULATE THE FINER POINTS
OF THIS. BILL THANK CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THIS IS THE ANNUAL.
SEVEN G. O. COMMITTEE BILL THAT
MADE IT IS WAY TOO MUCH ARE AS
WE HAVE A MOTION. ARE THERE ANY
ANYONE HERE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. ANYONE HERE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF THE BILL
SAYING NINE ANY QUESTIONS NAME
NINE. WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL THE MOTION IS TO CONQUER
WITH SENATE AND MEASUREMENTS
GRAY. HI GRAY EYES BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
BERMAN I BERMAN IPHONE SO.
BONTA I'D GROW. GROW I FULLY
ALL RIGHT COOLEY AYE COOPER.
UBER. IDEALLY DALY AYE
GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER AYE GARCIA
SEN ALL RIGHT GIPSON AYE JONES
SAWYER JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY
RIGHT LACKEY I'D LOW. LOW AYE
MATHIS MATHIS AYE MELENDEZ
MELENDEZ AYE QUIRK SILVA. WORK
SILVA I'D RIVAS. RUBIO HI RUBIO
AYE SALAS HI SALAS AYE. THE
BILL HAS EIGHTEEN VOTES MISTER
CHAIR. THE BILL GETS OUT YOU
WANT ONLY THE MEETING OPEN FOR
ADD ONS OR WOULD YOU LIKE TO
DISCLOSE. THIS MEETING WAS
EVERYBODY